hey 42 here what exactly
is an organism it seems a simple enough
question
but it's one that's befuddled biologists
for many years
you might think it's something along the
lines of a single living thing
or perhaps something that couldn't
function if it was split up
and both those answers aren't too
different to many of the standard
definitions out there
but it isn't quite as simple as that let
me give you an example
you watching this video are made up of
lots of individual cells
and when i say lots what i really mean
is about 40 trillion
every single one of those cells fulfills
both of the definitions i just mentioned
they are individual living things and if
you chop them up into pieces
they die they even reproduce another
common factor that crops up in
definitions of
what makes something an organism so does
that mean
you are not in fact one individual
organism
but a coalition of 40 trillion little
ones
well no the first each of your cells is
built from the same blueprint
your dna meaning they're genetically
uniform
but more importantly all of your cells
work together to serve a common purpose
keeping you alive evolutionary
biologists
david kweller and joan strassman
believed
this shared purpose is key to what makes
something
an organism they've devised their own
definition
which is that something is an organism
if
its parts work together for the benefit
of the
integrated whole with high cooperation
and low conflict what's particularly
interesting about this definition is
that it doesn't necessarily require
that an organism is an individual entity
a colony of honeybees for example could
be considered
a single organism because all the bees
work together for the good of the whole
just like all the cells in your body
work together to keep you alive
so with this definition in mind
which organism out there takes the prize
for being
the most humongous biomorphic mahousy
thing on the planet under some of our
old
outdated definitions of what an organism
is
one of the first creatures that springs
to mind is the undisputed heavyweight
champion of the animal kingdom
officially weighing in at 150 tons this
25 meter goliath
is universally recognized as the largest
animal
to have ever existed bigger even than
the mightiest dinosaur it's the
undefeated
champion of the sea with a tongue as
heavy as an elephant
the blue whale this magnificent mammal
was hunted almost to the point of
extinction
but thanks to the ban on blue whale
hunting in 1967
it's making a slow and steady comeback
but if you think 150 tons
is heavy that's nothing compared to our
next contender
weighing in at more than 6 000 tons
that's as much as 40 blue whales and
living high on a utah plateau
it's a morbidly obese panda just kidding
the heaviest organism in the plant
kingdom is in fact
a single quaking aspen tree named pando
that's taken over the fish lake national
forest
although pando can deceive its opponents
by disguising
itself as a forest of many regular sized
trees it's actually a single
clonal organism that grew from one
teeny tiny seed long ago and
since all 47 000 stems are part of the
same organism
the forest behaves very unusually indeed
in the autumn the leaves of every single
individual tree
turn from green to gold at the exact
same time and the colony can use its
vast network of roots
to distribute nutrients to different
areas as needed
if we're measuring size by height rather
than weight
then the plant kingdom has a second
contender for the largest organism
also from america it's a californian
redwood
named hyperion standing at a whopping
115 meters
hyperion is 19 meters taller than big
ben
and 22 meters taller than the statue of
liberty
and although it's already 600 years old
that's a young whippersnapper in the
world of trees
and biologists anticipate it will grow
even taller as it reaches adulthood
but oddly enough the title for the
largest organism on earth
doesn't go to a contender from the
animal kingdom
or the plant kingdom in terms of length
and
weight the winner overshadows the blue
whale
pando and hyperion it dwells in the blue
mountains in oregon
and is forced to weigh at least 35 000
tons that's around 3 000 fire engines or
1.5 sphinxes
if you're the kind of weirdo who likes
to weigh things in sphinxes
it uses an underground network to attack
and steal from others
and is widely seen as an unstoppable
menace
it's a fungus honey fungus to be precise
back in 1998 a team from the u.s forest
service
set out to investigate why so many trees
were dying
in the malair national forest their
tests showed that nearly all of them had
been
infected with a type of honey fungus
known as armillaria solidifies
that in itself probably didn't come as a
huge shock
this particular type of fungus is feared
by gardeners throughout the world
having gained a reputation as an
insidious parasite
that can kill off complete woodlands
quickly and without mercy
but the team wanted to know exactly how
many fungal bodies they were up against
one impressive if slightly disturbing
trait of honey fungi
is that they can identify and connect to
each other
knowing this trait the team took samples
from 112 dead and dying trees
around the forest and grew them in pairs
in petri dishes
by seeing which ones fused and which
ones rejected each other
the team found that 61 of the trees some
of which were nearly four kilometers
apart
had been struck by the same clonal
colony
in other words they'd all been taken
down by the same
single organism of honey fungus
the team calculated that this humongous
fungus
covered an area of around 10 square
kilometers
and could be more than 8 000 years old
antonio caluccio an award-winning
italian chef
loved a bit of honey fungus especially
with spaghetti sliced garlic and a bit
of fresh red chili
but he probably didn't cook the main
part of it because when most people talk
about fungus they're referring to the
delicate
often colorful fruiting body we see
growing above ground
the reproductive structures otherwise
known
as mushrooms but beneath its delicate
yellow brown mushrooms the hoodie fungus
is made up
of rhizomorphs black twisting rope-like
structures
that spread across landscapes in search
of new hosts
and mycelium if you've already seen my
video on magic mushrooms you'll know
mycelium
is a pretty big deal if you were to pull
up a mushroom from the ground
the mycelium would be the white stringy
stuff beneath it
that looks like an extreme death metal
band logo it's tenaciously strong
incredibly efficient at digesting food
and
perhaps most disturbingly of all
sentient
at least in a broad sense mycelium
knows you're there and if you were to
walk across the ground above it
it would sense your movements and
respond
yeah it kind of gives a romantic
woodland stroll
an entirely different vibe doesn't it
mycelium can even link the roots of
different plants together
acting like a kind of fungal internet
some plants use this tool for good by
giving nutrients to other plants in need
or warning them of threats others turn
to a life of cybercrime
and steel nutrients and the craftiest
attacked their main rivals by slowly
drip feeding
toxic chemicals into their connecting
mycelia
so we know mycelium is pretty useful
stuff
and plants and trees certainly use it to
their advantage
but what about fungus itself how can
something as
vast and sprawling as acelidopies
use mycelium to conquer an entire forest
well it comes down to two attributes
fungi are extremely good problem solvers
and they also have some seriously
innovative communication skills
if you were to arrange some soil in the
shape of great britain
place pieces of wood where the cities
would be and then introduce
a wood-eating fungus something pretty
amazing would happen
before long its mycelium would broadly
replicate
the existing uk motorway network
in other words it would figure out the
shortest distance
between each piece of food not only that
but if you've suddenly had an
overwhelming urge to channel godzilla
and destroy one of these roads
the fungus would simply use an
alternative pathway
until it was able to return the original
to its former glory
a skill that comes in extremely useful
when negotiating
vast and ever-changing forest landscapes
it's this impressive ability to solve
problems
find alternative solutions and even
remember original solutions that has
caused
many to question whether fungi are in
fact
intelligent and crazy as it sounds
it's definitely possible traditionally
academics have talked about the meaning
of intelligence within the context of
humans
which is probably why we tend to assume
intelligence requires a brain
or at the very least a kind of central
hub of activity
american psychologist louis leon
furstone for example
claimed intelligence partly depended on
the ability to reason
and produce words fluently something we
think
fungi aren't capable of just yet
hopefully
but more recently intelligence has been
viewed more
flexibly taking into account things like
the ability to solve problems making
choices between two different causes of
action
and communicate with particularly large
fungal bodies their method of
communication has been the focus of a
lot of research
how are they able to coordinate what's
happening in one part of their network
with another
especially when either part could be up
to four kilometers away
as is the case with acelidopies this
remains one of the big questions in
fungal biology
and there are a few ideas floating
around but one of the most exciting
possibilities
is that fungi use electricity to
communicate
rather than chemicals back in the 90s a
swedish researcher called stefan
olsen borrowed a microelectric rig
a fairly common piece of equipment in
neurobiology labs
from a colleague who was studying the
way nerve fibers fire in
moth brains being the inquisitive sort
he wanted to know what would happen if
he took the rig
and hooked it up to a fungal mycelium
network
his curiosity paid off because
it turned out mycelium did produce
spontaneous electrical impulses
olsen then introduced some blocks of
wood as a source of food for the fungus
and the speed of the impulses increased
suggesting the existence of a signaling
system fast enough to be used
by even the largest fungal bodies to
send and receive information
and the system that fast could only be
electrical
and the fun doesn't stop there what if
we
human beings could use this system of
electrical impulses
to listen to fungi and learn things from
them
i know it's the kind of question you'd
hear from your slightly eccentric and
highly intoxicated friend on the way
home from a long night out
but one man andrew adamanski tackled
this question
completely sober ademansky is a british
computer scientist and the director of
the unconventional computing laboratory
he's conducted all sorts of weird and
wonderful experiments in the past
like using slime molds as components of
nano-robotic systems
and to help out with city planning and
he thought your mate dave had a weird
job
he's also come up with the ingenious
idea that we could use
fungi as biological computing networks
basically if we plugged electrodes into
a mushroom and learned to decode its
electrical signals
we could theoretically pay attention to
what's going on in different parts of
its mycelia network
maybe even using it as a kind of
large-scale environmental
sensor three years ago adamanski applied
a range of different stimuli to oyster
fungi
including changes in light temperature
and mechanical pressure
as well as chemicals like chloroform to
make them sleepy
and even cortisol to stress them out a
little bit
by analyzing the resulting spikes in
electrical activity
he found the fungi responded differently
to each different stimulus
and that it was possible to map their
responses
and interpret them adamanski has
suggested this system could be used to
tell us things about a fungus natural
environment
things like the health of the forest it
inhabits
the way other trees and plants are
distributed within it
or even the funguses intentions
like where it wants to grow yes fungi
can be picky
and right now he and his team at uwe
bristol
are developing a revolutionary type of
smart building
made with fungi one that can react to
changes in
light temperature air pollutants
and even perhaps a little disturbingly
the presence of people within it living
fungi grown inside the building
structure
will act as a sensor to detect these
different stimuli
and then computers will analyze the
information
when particular changes are recognized
the system will respond
by controlling connected devices like
lights and heaters
so we're not yet at the point of
speaking directly to fungi ourselves
but we're certainly figuring out more
inventive ways to interact with them
than simply frying them up with
spaghetti and it feels fairly
collaborative
at least for now but next time you
purchase a pack of button mushrooms at
the supermarket
just remember they may be tasty and
bite-sized but
they have a big brother that's larger
than you and
larger than any other organism in
existence
it's probably sentient and might soon
be occupying your home thanks for
watching
you can get your hands on my book stick
a flag in it over
on amazon or on audible links to both in
the description below
thank you